they try to let go that attention this
is a a relase Dr for you
hey there you go more and then you you
tap out you just tap out it's not a pain
it's not supposed to be a pain
hey
release release come
on
release more
he release
four
[Music]
more more
he all right so we'll just look at this
hand here okay he's pushing right
this hand's going to go around to
here then I'm not going to do just
internal or I'm relax like you can do
that
okay but we're going to combine it with
the inertial
engines and so it's light you see that's
where I am okay and then the inertial
engine
creates the front inward kazushi
by okay and then this is where I do my
Niko but my Niko doesn't stay in the
wrist there is a check
right but it's in the
center
so I don't want to go here and use my
arm to get in the right
place my arm stays where it is this is
all I get and I move to take off
pressure it's
all
I don't want to stay on the
line I move off the line cuz that's
the front inward
okay
get the M right hey
all right the Niko
itself so it's not that I'm here and
then from here I push on that
[Music]
Center I'm in I'm in the
Nel but I'm not here in the
wrist there is a Nel okay you you know
there is right okay but I'm not just
going to take him down in his wrist
okay I have the Nel so there is a
downward
check but it moves
him you
see there it
is but it's moving
it because you want want him off balance
though you don't want him just in
pain If he if he moves if he moves with
his Center then the lock there's no lock
okay but there is
[Music]
kazushi no lock is you understand
lock so you kind see there's a a dness
to it's not
here
downward but in his
Center
then
um his hand is way bigger than
mine
okay there's no way don't don't hurt me
okay and then I don't have thumbs
because my my thumbs have been broken
too many times over the
decades so I don't have the
strength to turn that just you could you
see be surprised how weak that thumb is
on me you see
okay so a couple things here don't grab
his
thumb when his hand is way bigger than
yours you can't I can't get there I I
don't need to get there the technique is
on the metac car pulse here you see that
he you you do that a lot
so on
Sonu right you have ways I push his
pinky behind his fingers and now my
small hands can grab his major fingers
do you see but I leave your pinky there
and I don't have much grip I push this
pinky behind and now I have a grip you
have this concept A Lot okay so don't
try to grab the
thumb you're on the metacarpal okay and
then your Technique isn't in the wrist
so let's for example as I try to drive
this I would feel his y energy so as I
feel the Y energy that is telling me I
will change what I'm doing with all the
other planes okay okay so like that's as
far as you can go but look I can go this
way now you see you get that as opposed
to going down down down no I can't go
anymore cuz I don't have the strength
but now I can move him likewise the
other hand it reaches its Yang Max while
the other hand now enters it y face you
see that so you don't be up here they're
together and they
work
then you go back to your
[Music]
M very relaxed but he can't push you see
never going to push at no point is he
able to push push me over
no they don't have your hands go in and
out you're going to get pushed
over
okay clean up the
KNE all right so uh remember his arm is
making one big since I'm on uh his left
side one big
counterclockwise
Circle it should not at any
point he's going
around should not at any point come back
and then go
one counterclockwise
veral keep it
static
one
constant
spiral
resist the
temptation it's going the other
way going straight
out went
backwards finally went back to original
time
okay one constant
Circle tightening tightening downward
spiral here we
go uh control
maintenance you do have an inertial
engine here as he's
falling but you you don't want it to
have no control where he could get back
up if he was athletic I would just
reverse the
film just reverse
it um you
go
again
see you'll feel the in
space wait for it there's no
Yin right there it is you see
he everyone just lays
down so I understand he's going down you
get
it but uh as he goes to stand
up there's control points do you got it
he um you wouldn't necessarily be
turtled I I've lost you my friend lay
lay
down and I want you to feel it it's
right there
yes don't be so anxious there's plenty
blend that's
it you guys see this
now you're still two egges trust it it's
there
he why are you pushing it
out find the in space it's going to be
up right there there it is tight okay
you guys see it now
okay so as I brought this to
here I am not going to give him
that so I pushed down here and this
control Point does not
change it will change
shape it'll go from here to here but for
you it's elbow elbow right right okay
then this hand all you let
go and wait for it to go back on here's
where your body comes into play okay so
my body goes
here it's not there you you could
tap and I'm rolling
around do you
see do you guys see that it's no
different than in NE Wasa and you use
your body so get down on
mounts right and he's pushing up
I'm not going to go like this and then
come down and get arm cross face so as
he's pushing up you see I use my body to
do the same
thing were you able to get it yes okay
so you got him here you're going to give
up a control point so you have to
replace it with another one and it's
your body your body is
good okay so watch How I don't take his
hand completely off my
body as we're coming
around it's on my body and in fact my
body is doing this not my
arms this why I hug hug
myself
okay so feel for when you get your
adhesion
points that are not only restricted to
your hands a lot of times it's your body
okay all right let's try okay and don't
undo that spot where only the laying
down victim would get up okay we we have
many videos on the
end uh but still it eludes us okay his
elbow has to be on the front side of my
spine so here's my spine line okay his
elbow can't be on
the spine definitely not on the other
side you won't have the
engine capable of dealing with it the
pin his elbows on the front
side and then the pin is not in my waist
cuz nothing's in my waist it's not in my
arms because nothing should be in my
arms so I'll do my
qua and then I'll turn my tonden forward
down because it's K hole here which is
what it is it's K hole it's not a pin
because here in
modern this is nothing more than the
Kimura and nothing
stopping the forward
roll
okay so for example if I was doing the
omop plaza which is the same thing I got
to stop that ability to roll then I get
the
L this is coku
hole this is where I turn the
tanden into this forward
cycle
down okay so I turn the quaw and then I
drop
it got it that's what I'm doing it's
cul because it's
concentric then the the art is
concentric it is how to do a lock on the
shoulder mechanism so what I'm doing
here is not an
elbow but I'm going to take this scapula
mechanism move it
forward and down
okay so if I'm if I'm here like this and
I'm moving it forward and down and I get
another lock
going then I'll have a pin try to roll I
can't
okay so I am doing a shoulder lock it's
just this is not a
pin I use a shoulder lock and use cou
hole okay
so get it in the right place let's turn
this
way to free your
mind because it's not a
pin and it's khole I'm not going to turn
my waist I'm not going to use my
arms I understand what I'm trying to do
to the shoulder
mechanism only this knee is
important this knee is not
important meaning it does not have to
be pinching his
shoulders as if that did anything
magical okay um so here I
am the elbows on my center line or even
over I have my magic hands and I'm
pitching his shoulder and just stand up
Sean
okay what this knee
does it does not need the other knee for
is it stops him going
forward so that knees there elbows in
front front turn the qua and then rotate
the tanden
forward and you'll get the pin okay all
right let's try
it so the whole time you're training you
have releasing they're they're just
releasing drills really but especially
on the ukis side okay um so as as I go
you see me here right okay I'm going to
one stay there once I press I felt my
own tonden formed you see as the two y
energies are hitting each other so now I
keep that feeling in my
body and I don't lose
it tension in the limbs is going to make
me lose
it Bo
the mat is y energy
too you
see I have to
reconcile with the mat as
well
no
smooth
accepting
releasing
all
right hey there is no
pain you're in you're resisting the pain
shows out okay try to